hello there I'm keV I'm Dan we're the
slow mo guys Dan one of my favorite
treats back when I lived in the UK was a
lovely Packer Maltesers yeah never use
to be able to get them in America but
they've recently launched in the US so
they're all over the gaff now so we
thought being from England why not give
them our own slow mo guys launch yeah a
hundred feet per second with this
massive air cannon hello America I'm
here and we're gonna film it at
ridiculous frame rates on the Phantom V
2511 shall we start with a melon
let's I've got one right here let's do
it
all right so how does this device work
then kind of complicated but we've got a
high-pressure nitrogen here fed through
a tube all the way into here which is
like a regulator valve now this when it
makes a sound oh right it's good filling
up the chamber with pressure okay up to
150 psi which is regulated by that when
it stops making noise
that means it's full all right okay so
now we've got our gas in here and this
is like our valve to release it so it's
armed then you press fire and that's
what releases the gas solenoid it's
called it yes that's right hold on
venturi here increases the pressure
going into the chamber and this here is
our chamber where we load the malteaser
in okay so that's where we go and if it
fits it sits so you put it in there
screw it up
yeah and then we've got our tube here it
gets fired along here with the pressure
and our object that's gonna be
imminently destroyed sits here that's
the goodbye zone yeah this isn't gonna
be here for when we're shooting stuff
but this is a tester to find out how
fast stuff goes what's our highest
malteaser so far fluke one nine hundred
feet per second which is faster than a
45 caliber round comes out the muzzle of
a pistol so it's pretty use a fire or I
might just be sitting there with a
pistol yeah yeah all right and then it
then we got a backboard over there to
catch the mess yes absolutely
screw this up that's all chamber cool
okay so I'm gonna gas the tube are me
three two one
oh goodness me I think we need to clean
our gloss
yeah it comes with a lot of air hate to
adjust the exposure air that and spray
this so bright
yeah alright I think we should do that
again so we've seen what happens with
one more teaser but happens if we do two
more teasers got to it see if you can
bung both of them in there hey what if
it gasps good sound and that's so meaty
three two one oh bloody yeah that was
loud
you got it over there got watermelon
brains on me here's our unsuspecting
watermelon just chilling out that was a
really good escalation yeah what do you
think the term is that gap I mean no
idea I mean Maltesers aren't perfectly
round so maybe that's just like their
different shapes caused them to come
through it at the time that's opened it
up but can absolute you there we
definite Visser Asian look at the chunks
how does something as light as a
malteaser sorry to Maltesers do that or
watermelon you do you'd need to use a
sledgehammer to get that effect as a
human meant yeah yeah unbelievable guys
at the furthest chunk that's the
furthest chunk I've seen that must be
gonna see if far more teasers we'll go
through a soda pop can ready yep three
two one whoa
Oh
the second one is so funny sir yeah it's
always like way too late to do anything
about it was like the can was a human
and got punched in the gut the way it
buckled down like yeah I did
controlling on the laptop today because
their doors so I'm gonna reduce the
resolution on this one it's a 512 by 320
not remotely HD or even SD we're gonna
shoot a 118 thousand frames a second
just to get that crushing impact to the
malteaser around here army right 3 2 1
oh I like how it seems to make you jump
every time you're the one doing it
you're like yeah
this is 102 you see the tear on the
condo right it's so quick
I always want to see that frame by frame
yeah oh wow that's amazing
ah got that flowering effect that's so
cool so he might went popped it flattens
itself so a lot of the energy is
absorbed by itself but it still has
enough for that is that malteaser
they're just bits of malteaser crushed
yeah so I was looking and I was
wondering if I could find the piece of
can that the multi with it I wondered if
it just like shattered the can although
they were just split it and go through
apparently not because I found the exact
piece the Maltese are here it's even
concaved like a sphere from a multi look
at it yeah perfectly here so we're
getting a bit more substantial this time
ping pong bat here do you think it'll go
through I think it will go through I
have to make you don't think it'll go
through now cuz plywood's always layered
isn't it it's layered to be strong now
go through oh go through yeah right
three two one oh oh what did it go
through or did it go through it was
nothing I owe you 10 bucks you do bugger
me couldn't be clearer it's like a
bullet hole oh jeez look at that exit
there that is a nasty exit wound I
perfect morteza sighs like I was a bit
worried because I thought is it gonna
ping back and hit me
he's you see the ripple of the rubber
there that would just flying out the
back yeah well I cannon you know we've
been shooting lot of stuff that's like I
knew would go like a melon or a drink
that surprised me
I don't know why it surprised me
considering with speeds and the air from
the cannon is like going poop yeah got
the fast camera got a fast malteaser
perfect for smashing some glass how do
you feel that about visors yeah got a
few of them oh-ho yeah yeah like them
why'd you hate this one so much ranked
three two one
we were yet to beat these more teasers
man what can't they destroy this glass
is thick now that was weird
it went and hit and it looked like its
stock and then then we'll to yourself
went into itself and then it went in war
yeah it was like it like the bars
absorbed all the Maltesers power and
just shattered your heart I want to see
that frame by frame there's one frame in
there that looks astonishing well maybe
there that's the one hit here the motion
blur on that so we've done of ours right
so we've done involved I thought we
could do a vast but filled with
different color paint I just I feel like
you're just trying to make the biggest
mess possible yeah three two one whoa
that is the bigger mess than I was
expecting that is another point Oh No
take just it's amazing how much of it
went forwards yeah that's just baloney
completely away it's like a black hole
engulfing a planet imagine if you hadn't
covered the camera with a plexiglass
[Music]
so now we've made this giant mess let's
revisit the ping pong bat and get a
gnarly exit wound shall we yeah see if
we can see all the wood flying out the
back bet you ten bucks it goes through
I'm not taking a bet I might put another
ping put another malteaser in there just
to see it come through the hole that
we've already made both that's a good
idea so it's like exit wound and then
yeah three two one whoa just took the
bow off bloody yeah just removed the bat
instead oh and it went as well
it went through - I wonder if just be
left over ere from there the last
straight through its dust the other one
turned to dust as well the other one
came through the hole but it was all
sort of ripped up so it just became
nothing also then now there's blowing it
off the handle yeah I think a lot of it
is to do it on the other to the other
turn it was nailed but also a lot of the
powder was behind the plank and because
it was on the other side it was had less
strength in that direction so we fired
through quite a lot of stuff with more
teasers right so far we've found that it
seems to obliterate on the first hit
yeah so I thought we could do a test
where we put three more teasers right in
the chamber we have three pieces of
glass and we see if the first time I
smash the first pane second smash the
second pane and third on the third so
we're gonna see if it's like a
one-to-one yeah three four three sort of
basis I'm wondering if it'll get we can
go bang bang bang because we know they
follow it quite but here's the thing
though by the third one it's gonna be
going through the shards and debris of
the two panes yeah so I don't think this
one will break you don't think it will I
think this one will definitely that one
yeah no yeah three two one oh wow damn
it gone through all three I wonder if it
will be as I as I hoped where each
individual one smashed its own pane of
glass Oh a safety glass oh you'd hear it
you can hear the lovely safety glass
popping
[Music]
okay season one through the first page
it's just no come on come on
yes I've done it well tease number two
I'm gonna thread the needle or is that
oh wait if it shatters beforehand it did
so the bad ones made it through though
is it gonna make it through it's so fast
the tiny shards of chocolate eNOS and
glossiness actually destroyed the third
pane now what we need to do is lit up
with twenty and get 25 how many can we
get through now we're gonna switch up
the camera and the angle to get some
much wider higher resolution shots of
the destruction but we've run out of
more teasers that's right we'll just
open another bucket let's do it three
two one I like how the air has gone in
through the hole out through the
malteaser waiting smashed it all that
air filled it and the lid blew up yeah
through the hole you know I like about
pineapples go on pretty much everything
but I would prefer if this pineapple was
over there and a bit on the wall
luckily we have the perfect contraption
that so three two
come on look at this footage this is a
perfect example of why we needed to use
the other camera because this is the
malteaser
what you caught the frame of it the
malteaser apparent is this long so our
exposure time here is about a three
thousandth of a second so in one three
thousandth of a second it moved from
there to there goodness make that streak
so it's a good job we got all the other
shots on the on the first camera is the
slow-motion camera that can't even see
it one frame of malteaser so this is our
pineapple before after just looks like
someone's taking a big bite out of it
except it was a malteaser sort of bite a
horse took avaya yeah three two one
so one thing I've noticed while using
the Phantom flex at like 1600 fps is
that the malteaser is fast as heck it's
just like one street keeps like a streak
of yeah so now we're going to film it
from a standstill as it accelerates all
the way up to the end of the pipe and I
think for a nice scale speed reference
if you just drop them or teaser at the
same time so you can sort of see you
know that's gravity and that is how fast
that's moving in comparison yes so I've
got to trigger it and drop at the same
time yeah I think by the time I've let
go it'll already be at the end yeah just
don't trigger it before you let go so I
let go and trigger
alright cool I think I can manage that
yeah the thing is I wonder if you could
tell the acceleration as well like if
it's a small blur here and then a faster
bigger blur here it should be Maltese
are grabbed right 3 2 1 I put time that
right hey look what you did yeah the
malteaser has been released
release it Maltese it looks like it's
space isn't it looks like I'm in space
it I don't let something go well teaser
inside hasn't started moving yet I
reckon it'll be about there before it
does I have to tell me was I completely
missed it
ok ready yeah oh yeah so how far did it
move when it was dropping that
centimeter maybe like from there they
move like one length of itself so it
moved one malteaser
so in the amount of time it took from it
for it to get from the beginning to the
end of the barrel that is a very good
speed comparison it took 1 malteaser
well then I thought that was a fantastic
amount of destruction a nice piece of
art as well as we usually do yeah do you
think malteaser has ever gone that fast
absolutely not there's no way and
malteaser has gone that fast before
you'd have to buy fire into space or
something or just take a packet of
Maltesers on a plane and take them could
that be faster wouldn't it all right no
no ok fine fine I mean maybe like
relative to someone else three feet away
one's never moved
thanks to more teasers for sponsoring
this video yeah I always appreciate a
company the less has advertised their
products by absolutely trashing them
always
there's none left feel free to follow us
on Twitter subscribe to this channel
we've got a second channel to and we
will see you very soon for the next
video give us a click waves